A new video made in conjunction with value school.
And I don't think it's going to leave you in different.
[Inaudible].
Over the last decade, we have witnessed a complete technological revolution.
We have seen business models grow and consolidate in completely new areas,
smartphones via commerce, social media, and even video on demand platforms.
New Colossus is like Apple, Amazon, Facebook, Alibaba, alphabet, Netflix,
or even Tesla have become the biggest stars in them.
But.
Here's a question for you.
Can you tell me which listed company has achieved the greatest increase over the
last decade? Well,
take a look at this because it's not any of the companies that I've just
mentioned, and it has nothing to do with the NASDAQ or new technologies.
According to data from Bloomberg. If we consider MSEI world index companies,
that is an index that brings together medium and large capital companies in
developed countries,
the best performing company in the stock market is none other than a New Zealand
company in the dairy sector. Yes, we have stumbled upon the Kiwis.
Wait talking about a two milk and note that the difference is really good.
Great.
[inaudible].
Hey, two milk is a fairly young company created in 2000, between 2010 and 2019.
It has achieved an increase in the stock exchange.
Are you ready for this really crazy figure of more than 16000%,
which is an annual return of just over 66% for an entire year.
Decade.
It's not all over the past five years.
The annual profitability of its shareholders has been even higher between 2015
and 2019.
This stock has average an annual return of almost 80% in this period alone.
The price of its share has gone from about 95 cents in 2015 to closing at a
price of almost $18 in 2019.
What's more even the Corona virus.
Hasn't made a dent in it since the beginning of the year.
And until the end of July, this company has reaped an increase of almost 40%.
In other.
Words, if in the summer of 2015,
we decided to invest 10,000 pounds in this New Zealand dairy company today just
five and a half years later,
the shares would be worth more than a quarter of a million.
Dollars. And.
If, instead of waiting until 2015, we had carried out the investment earlier,
let's say 2010.
Then we would be talking about a jackpot of more than $2 million,
specifically about $2,727,000
to be more accurate.
It's sheer madness that has made a small New Zealand company become in just 10
years, a food giant valued at almost $10 billion.
[Inaudible].
Do you know what the best thing of all is that this company doesn't even have?
What explains such a rapid rise?
Are we dealing with some kind of rampant bubble in the dairy sector?
How has this company achieved such success in such a basic and at the same time,
highly saturated market? Well.
Let's take a look, a different protein.
You get to the beginning of this.
We have to go back to before the turn of the century,
back to the year 1993 that's year two Kiwis to New Zealand scientists,
Bob Elliott,
and Karen McLachlan who were researching diabetes and heart disease identified
milk as a possible.
Bridge.
Not all types of milk, but specifically the variety known as a one,
which is the type of milk that is marketed in virtually every country in the
world.
Well.
So their research,
this type of milk was identified as possibly leading to inflammatory processes
in the digestive system,
a problem experienced by approximately 25% of the population at the same time,
they also indicated that another type of milk known as a tube may not have these
harmful effects.
To clarify.
Let's explain what these two types are. You see,
we can say that all milk contains two types of protein,
18% corresponding to that part known as whey protein and the remaining 82% to
casein in turn, we can find three types of casein, alpha beta and Kappa. Well,
the beta casein can be either type a one or type a two in the past.
Cows produced only the two proteins,
but apparently from a cell mutation that occurred about a hundred thousand years
ago in Europe, cows began producing the [inaudible] beta casein protein.
These cows can produce more milk, making the, a one type cattle,
the favorites of farmers throughout the world.
Since.
Then studies on this issue have multiplied with results for all tastes. Yes,
a one type milk really has problems. No, it doesn't have them.
Then a two milk is better than it's not et cetera, et cetera,
as you can probably imagine,
the conclusions have usually had a lot to do with those who sponsored the
studies. However, at this point in time,
it seems that the majority of scientific opinions suggest that this alleged
damage from type Awan milk is.
Prove it.
For example, what the European food safety or authority points do,
but let's stop the scientific debate. The fact is that in 2000 Koren McLachlan,
one of the two New Zealand scientists,
we mentioned earlier partnered with entrepreneur Howard Patterson to found the
[inaudible] milk company with the aim of distributing milk and a two type dairy
product.
[Inaudible].
And you know what,
beyond the debate about whether a two type milk is actually better or not,
the truth is that this company has effectively used the marketing of this
different type of milk to consolidate a premium brand.
Something that along with the perception, that it may be easier to digest,
allow them to multiply sales in New Zealand, Australia, and all syringe.
When they released their infant formula,
a product that has had spectacular results in the Chinese market.
It's a country where families are particularly concerned about the quality of
milk consumed by the youngest,
especially after the countries 2008 contaminated milk crisis,
which caused more than 50,000 newborn children to be hospitalized.
And.
It's here where this New Zealand company has found a way to break through,
because let's say that a two milk didn't want to be a typical milk distribution
company, but that its goal has been to become a complete marketing company. Yes.
Marketing. And that that's exactly what explains it. Stock market performance.
Listen up a business success.
16000% Up. Are we dealing with a bubble? Well,
more like a spectacular growth story in the last five years alone,
the company has managed to multiply its sales by almost 12 times. And in 2020,
they expect a further increase of more than 30%.
And it's not just.
About income and increased operating profits.
Hasn't been slow in happening either the projections for the company's interest
in pre-tax profits expected by the end of 2020, uh,
greater than the company's entire market value was in 2015.
Eight.
It's a company that has so far been operating in New Zealand, Australia,
and China, but which has just taken on the giant UBS.
Smack it.
But at this point,
the burning question is how has this small company achieved such success?
What makes this business tick? Well,
you see the most surprising thing about it is that Adrian milk is not really a
food producer. That is,
it is a very unusual dairy company because all of its products are manufactured
by third party suppliers,
suppliers with which the company maintained strong ties as is the case with
scintillate milk,
a New Zealand dairy company that lists a two milk is its second largest
shareholder controlling 20% of.
The shares.
Are we still talking about third party companies, as we told you before,
82 milk is basically a distribution and marketing business.
The goal of its managers is to feed demand,
take care of the distribution chain and strengthen its brand image.
And this has really important advantages. For example,
they don't need to invest in capital. It may be surprising,
but over the past five years,
a two milk has managed to increase its annual sales by more than 1.5 billion,
New Zealand dollars by investing in fixed capital totalling just $9 million.
Yes, yes, that's correct.
Just 9 million New Zealand dollars about us $6 billion in the current exchange
rates in this way,
the company not only does not need large lines of credit or to assume large debt
commitments, but also the bulk of the profits. It generates are in cash.
Cash.
Thanks to the fact that it does not have to make huge investments in fixed
capital and face. All the associated costs.
The company achieves an operating margin of more than 30%.
That is at the same level as the big technology companies in the union.
Basically.
The only task of managers is to take care of the brand, develop markets,
design marketing campaigns, and look for new ways to fuel demand. For example,
one of the keys to its growth in China was that the company was a pioneer among
food companies and exploiting the power of e-commerce for example, via Alibaba.
Anyway.
It was the strategy and the spectacular growth that its business has recorded is
what explains the incredible increase that this company had on the stock
exchange. However, even having all the available numbers,
if you think that its stock market evaluation has been a quiet riot,
you couldn't be more wrong.
During.
The last five years alone,
we can see in the evolution of the stock price that on three occasions,
the share price plummeted more than 30%.
Can you imagine being a shareholder and selling your shares for fear of failing,
even if the business was going so very well, it would have been hard.
16000%.
Take note though, because something similar happens to the format,
a two milk shareholder, the Australian company, freedom foods.
This company had 20% of the shares. However,
after a frustrated attempt to take over the entire company,
it decided to liquidate its entire stake in 2015 for just over 60 million
euros. The day just five years later,
that same stake would be worth more than $2 billion,
which is more than the entire market capitalization of the freedom foods
company. So, you know, be very careful in selling a good business to soon.
Anyway.
This is the story of a,
to milk the company with the best stock market performance of the last decade.
A company that is dedicated to a business as traditional as milk has managed to
exceed the profitability generated by Silicon Valley's largest companies.
I really hope you've enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform,
please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
Yeah.